leute bei 5000 rentner ihr team die
augenbrauen im staat
du hast ja brutal war ein video ja heute
erst mal ich hoffe natürlich euch jetzt
tut mir geht's auch sehr gut zumindest
noch auf jeden fall das video heute
entsteht mega spontan ich bin irgendwie
heute morgen drauf gekommen und war also
klar so ich habe zwei stunden heftigsten
buttons aber ab und zu habe ich mich
halt auch mal im gesicht und vorstand
schlagen unter der dusche und habe mir
gedacht ich kann das nicht mal wieder
rasieren weil ich schon fast hatte man
keine haare im gesicht hat weil mir das
nicht so steht probleme angefreundet und
rasierschaum weil er hat ihn macht
eigentlich jedes mal dann stand ich
daran dass wir du hast du was machst du
jetzt und der juli der benutzer hat
immer wieder mein vater schon der oft
etwas gedreht und wir haben halt eine
flasche unter der dusche stehen und ich
habe mir gedacht hey das ist ja auch so
derzeit ein kann man damit auch sich
rasieren das ist ja eine angebrachte
frage oder nicht natürlich normal
regiert frauen träumen
irgendwie andere chemikalien drin aber
mit muss das doch auch gehen ja dann kam
mir die wundervolle idee mich einfach
mal mit blut zu rasieren
allerdings war ich das ganze natürlich
vor kamerapositionen idee ja wir wissen
aber ich muss am anfang zu viel aber ich
bin dann auf jeden fall mal aufgestanden
und ich hab dann von der bestimmten
kooperation mit bekommen zwischen baby
und braus und zwar besteht diese
formation leute denen auch kurz vorweg
einkaufen weil das solch einen fußball
doch da also läuft das habt ihr noch
nicht gesehen liegen jetzt ein haufen
leute jetzt ab zurückfahren und der
bibliothek auf
so läutet dieser rossmann da er hat
irgendwie kein populärer des in die
stadt fahren ja ich muss jetzt in die
richtige city fahren damit ich gern ein
blue epilierer kriegen dran und ich habe
dort noch ein einzelner hat irgendwie
ein bisschen drunter
natürlich will auch mal dass dies über
die 70 euro als klar in seinen letzten
tagen wirklich sehr sehr hart gearbeitet
und hat mir gesagt anlässen kleines
geschenk für dich selber ist drin und
deswegen habe ich mir wie ich die
falschen weg ist ihr letztes tritt
weniger gekauft ich meine wahl angebote
zu eurem kostet und du jemand wichtig er
schlicht dazu das ist ganz klar was
anderes brüssel eine kleine überraschung
[Musik]
autogrammkarten batterien und aufgabe
ich kann damit auch mein plan ist schon
brutal aus oder
[Musik]
der fall ist es ist jetzt gesichert
klar ist nur tauschen das verfolgt
maschine und was euch hier mitmachen
dich baby nicht lumpen lassen batterien
mit zu dienen also wie die vielen dank
für die batterien
wenn ich das nicht mehr brauche dann tue
ich das in und fern werden in die halle
mit 61 stunden später also im ersten ist
schon cool also die frage ist derzeit
nur wirklich wach effekt hat einige gar
nicht auf der liste
das einzige was ist hier willkommen
zurück zu grundidee und war ich fliege
morgen nach ibiza und ich habe mir
gedacht es muss auf jeden fall meine
arbeit behaarung was du nein ich bin
nicht schwul ich finde so für den besten
start luca manchmal ein bisschen die
beine rasieren oder und deswegen habe
ich mich jetzt einmal an den beinen mit
dem babyblues augen rasierer und an
diesem an diesem einheit mitnehmen wie
braun epilation sie hat noch mal die pdl
epiliergerät worauf er ist hierzu
geweckt ich will gar nicht lange lagern
das heißt wenn es wirklich funktioniert
heute wir brauchen in zukunft kein
rasierschaum er wir brauchen einfach wie
du wie ich hier gut und kontrollieren ob
du vielleicht eine infomappe ich habe
heute das neue kaufen fahrt chocolate
cupcake ein halter jetzt locker
schokolade fans müssen das irgendwie ich
stell dir vor du bist einfach nach
schokolade sondern du schützt durch und
sagen mit welchem gesicht wahren
das glaube ich zu hart okay leute ich
muss sagen schreibt alle jetzt in die
kommentare
ob ihr meint dass es funktioniert also
mit below und im rasierer oder ob das
nicht geht weil ich ja logisch einfach
nur kann man sich nicht rasieren das tut
mir weh und dann schneidet man sich das
video heute wieder auf jeden fall wieder
sehr qualitativ hochwertig und
interessant
hey mama verlassen
der zuschauer ist auf jeden fall von 1
das überhaupt die chance da ist auf
jeden fall die usa erst eingezogen und
stimme zwar gespannt wenn ich ihre was
hier auf das technisch funktioniert
einfach nicht errungen so miteinander
stehen die frage ist ja einfach so alles
weg durchs all ein baby heißt epilation
sting oder wir dominiert weil ein
ständiger vergessen vielleicht auch ihre
familien brauchen
münster die börslichen die beschreibung
schon hier
das gibt es einfach auch russisch
türkisch polnisch zu wenig noch weg ich
musste ganz das baby auf italienisches
einsatz kommen also wenn sie auch
trockene haut epilieren mit ihrer haut
frei von fett oder creme sein habe ich
trockenen haut das gerät kann auch auf
nasse haut angewendet werden sogar unter
fließendem wasser stellen sie sicher
dass ihre haut gut angefeuchtet es für
optimales gleichen können sie während
dem epilieren musst dir anwenden wie du
es auch okay der epi hier kopf könnte
auch in sexspielzeug sein
der fiel ihr kopf ist mit verschiedenen
aufsätzen ausgestattet 1 7 oder 8
abhängig vom modell wählen die den auch
das je nach ihren bedürfnissen
außer zur optimalen hautkontakt sorgt
für eine perfekte anpassung in allen
anwendungen massage auf das ja bla bla
bla epilation der beiden definieren die
die beine von unten nach oben bei der
anwendung an den kniekehlen muss ich
frag mich das ressort muss ich angst
habe oder nicht weil guck mal
es gibt zwei stufen und wenn ich das
dann aus machen will ist noch härter
erfolg einfach dazu total wo vielleicht
ich mache es jetzt nicht selber
[Musik]
beantworten wir eine frage woche hatten
vorteil für die leiden oder wir machen
das nicht wissentlich mit und sprach ihn
freischalten
[Gelächter]
damit kannst du durch schlaffe die
klapprig verletzten der leute bei 5.000
leicht kontrolliert in die augenbrauen
im darm eingeführt mich okay leute immer
noch auf den vorstufen das weltmeister
team stört sie sich mal vor das wird man
durch die haare machen also mit sich das
gericht bewerten dass ich weiß nicht
anbieter erfüllt sondern sein dürfen
aber zurzeit total wählen also leute
hier haben wir einmal besser haben
das ist mit die blut radierer und das
ist mit ihrer einfach brutal rausgezogen
okay ich bin komplett fertig das war ein
echt heftige schmerzen also und sich
auch leicht wenn man mit bewohner im
schlaf die augenbrauen etatisiert
liquidiert oder unserem gastautor
nächsten wochen die jagd auf die männer
vielleicht arbeiten wenn man bei
familien wir werden sehen aber 50.000
recht hoch mit anfassen zeigt auf jeden
fall flat oder instagram ab ich bin
jetzt die nächsten tag auf die bühne
bringen wird leider nicht kommen
vielleicht sonntag der mega cool wenn er
mir auf erfolg kommen echt coole
produkte nächster zeit vor allem weil
ich jetzt vergessen urlaub und ja haut
rein machst du was nicht nach ist
gefährlich